Hello. So, yes, who am I? As Alex said, I
am Nick Hehr. I am first and foremost and
empathetic community member and next I am
a Front‑End developer at a company called
namely, I'm also a Disney fan, that's
topical, if you want to talk to me later about
something, huge fan of the parks and movies,
I'm also a bouldering enthusiast, pretty big
here in Berlin and Germany in general, and
New York as well, where I'm from. And if you
haven't noticed yet, I have petty wicked
mustache. Oh, no, is the animation not working
(Wicked).
But important thing about this, it's not to
be touched, you wouldn't believe how many
times I've had to tell people that. (Laughing)
Jan knows what I'm talking about. So, why
do I care about what I'm speaking about today,
why do I care about empathy in general? And
I care because my badge ground is actually
in psychology, and degree in leadership as
well, so a lot around people and how people
work together it's very important to Maine
as part of my job professionally, I'm in constant
collaboration with designers to make sure
that their visual ideas get Translated to
the pages very efficiently and well. And also
working with back‑end developers to make
sure the data thaw create on the API side
comes to the Front‑End and is communicated
back and forth efficiently at the same time.
And then, I also love the community. This
is one of the reasons I chose to keep working
and as soon as I started learning about web
development and continued working in that
community because it's just so nice. And I
love every part of the community, it's just
so much fun for me. And then there's this
very specific group of people that should
care about this, about empathy in general
and that's everybody. Siriusly (Laughing).
But that is empathy? Empathy is the ability
to understand and share the feelings of another.
If anyone saw Myles talk had gentlemen correctJS
it's feeling with someone else, not for someone
else. And it's a very widely talked about
tool or resource for designers, and we'll
talk about it a lot just being empathetic
for your users and feeling how they would
feel, and seeing the world through the eyes
of someone else in order to create the best
user experience for them. But, how can we
take this and apply it to how we work with
other people? And how can we make our products
so much better by doing this? Because we're
so focused on tools these days that, and there's
just wonderful, how can we also focus on the
people behind those tools. That's kind of
around where empathy‑‑ the other side
of empathy comes from and this concept. And
first it came from using Twitter. I love Twitter,
it's such a great resource and medium for
connecting with people and learning more about
the community, but, there's a lot of people
out there, and it's sometimes leads to some
snap judgements because it's so easy to put
your thoughts out there and just fire off
a quick tweet into the Ether that someone
will read. And eventually those someones create
some kind of mob mentality that really just
starts to bumble me out, I think it bumbles
a lot of people out, toking on‑line and
going on Twitter, I think we need to be more
careful and take more care in order to make
this a better experience for everyone. And
so, I kind of broke down the other side of
empathy into four main tenants. And that comes
down to context, constructive feedback, communication,
and caring. And so I tell you all of this
to give you some context about why I'm up
here and what I'm speaking about. And why
you all should care about what I'm speaking
about. And so context is all these internal
and external things that influence how we
make decisions and how we take actions, and
how we affect others around us. And it relates
to the other side of empathy mostly because
you gnaw have heard un‑opinionuated frameworks
or libraries or things like that. But no one
is un‑opinionuated, the fact they chose
to use small module or framework is an opinion,
or to structure something one way or another
is an opinion.
Is no un‑opinionuated opinions (Laughs)
and we all have biases from either the conscious
or unconscious, they come from somewhere,
it's important to recognize that, where they
come from, when they happen. And listening,
that's super key to get context from anyone,
if you want to get it, you have to listen,
and in order to get, that sometimes you have
to ask why. Why do we do all these things?
Why does this happen? Why did you chose that
structure over this structure, this framework
over that framework. And by doing this, we
can set the example for others. And set the
example for gaining context, encouraging it
from others. And we‑‑ I do this at work,
and we we do this together using user stories,
when cryuating features or work flows, has
anyone herd of Gherkin before? Yes, raise
your hands? Awesome. Gherkin is pretty saw
some, not just for testing but for gaining
context from the people you're working with.
It captures the who, what and why of a requirement
in such a simple way. And it's not only trying
to think of the users, but we also are‑‑
our own biases influences the kind of Gherkin
statements that we make to recognize what
a user or yourself would want. And we're all
at this conference today, we all have opinions,
biases, it's important to remember context
when we go around today at breaks or at the
parties or throughout the entire what the
FEST and when doing that, when you hear something
that may differ from your own opinion, it's
important to take a deep breath and then clear
your mind of any of those biases, recognize
that they're there, but just try to push them
aside for a second. Ask why, remember just
be sincere, you want to know why they did
this. And then listen. And through that, you
might start gaining some constructive feedback.
And now, constructive feedback is very important,
that word "constructive" it's not criticism,
it's not negative feedback, and being constructive
is getting information that should help you
move forward or improve. It's not meant to
just say, this is what's wrong, it's supposed
to say this could be changed this way I'll
go further into that. But first how many of
you all remember the golden rule? If you don't
have anything nice to say, don't say it at
all. Yeah. Well, somewhere between when we
learn that and maybe primary school, kindergarten,
and somewhere along the way through maybe
middle school or secondary school we tend
to forget that. We don't really remember that
rule or interacting with others as we get
older and go into the workforce or interacting
with other people in the community. And it's
nays to remember not to say if you don't have
anything nice to say‑‑ but in the context
of empathy, I want to change it a little and
say if you tonight have anything constructive
to say, then don't say anything at all. Not
saying something nice isn't good, but in the
terms of getting good constructive feedback,
we want to get constructive feedback saying
that's awesome! Doesn't move it forward, that's
the important part about this tenant. It's
moving something forward for the better to
improve upon. And some say negative feedback
can do that too, I mean, I go to Twitter sometimes
and I see people who have a snap judgments
where it's just like this is awful, and it's
like, can you tell me why it's awful? Can
you tell me more? And they say, it's‑‑
the negative tweets will help influence the
designers or developers behind such a product,
but good feedback, good constructive feedback
takes more than 140 characters, even less
than that when you mention the company or
the developers or the designers. And sometimes
they agree, but, they don't necessarily follow
through. Or we don't. And constructive feedback
is importantly a mutually agreed upon event.
It is set up with the expectations that you
are getting feedback, that we're getting feedback.
It's in an open space, not necessarily physically,
but somewhere that someone can feel like they
can remove themselves pretty simply and it's
also shared with context. We give our context
behind our constructive feedback in order
to make‑‑ to help the others understand
why we're giving it this way or what we're
talking about. And a perfect situation for
this, especially when working with others
is code reviews. Either if you do this at
work or part of an Open Source project, code
reviews are the perfect situation because
they follow every part of that constructive
feedback rules. It's intended to find mistakes
and fix them and hope to improve, to push
forward, not just the quality of the software,
but the developer skills as well. And it's,
you have that dedicated meeting or dedicated
time to come together and go over someone
else's project feature or code and it's coming
from everyone in the project, not just developers,
designers and manager's in hopes to give them
an understanding of what's going on and hopefully
the questions they ask will help you understand
your understanding of what you actually did.
Many times we go through something it works
maybe we're not sure why, they help us push
forward and improve on that that's all about
encouraging constructive feedback, we can
do it in the open in the community, and first
and foremost with a contributing.md. If anyone
knows what that is, it's a pretty awesome
little trick with GitHub that if you add this
file to any Repo, it's automagically link
opening an issue or pull request with that
contributing MD file what it takes and what
they're looking for when opening issue, opening
a pull request, submitting code, and some
of my favorites have been Atom, the Atom project
from GitHub. It's very thorough. It talks
all about what they're lacking for from issues,
what they're looking for from code, style
guides and things like that. It really helps
delay the shallow constructive feedback that
comes from pull requests and issues and helps
push forward to actual improvements that we
want. Of course, I'm also a little biased
for Hoodie, it's such a great project and
such a great contributing.md to help others
understand, even the READMEs are great contributing
files, just in case people can't get to this
up front. And, this type of linking and medium
is all about communication. And how to communicate
with people. And it's important to remember
that communication is sharing information
and ideas and feelings, especially in terms
of empathy. If you're talking to someone,
you're not necessarily communicating with
them. You're just spitting ideas at them,
and they're not taking them or sharing them
if you have to remember how to receive ideas
in order to communicate. And it's how we interact
with each other in general. And it's what
we say, how we say it, and where we say it,
like I said before, with the constructive
feedback, it's in a dedicated space or area
that people feel comfortable in. How we saw
it comes in the way we phrase things sometimes.
"I" statements. That're great for giving constructive
feedback, part of that context that we're
giving. I noticed or I found before that this
plug‑in tends to be a little inaccessible.
But for getting context, it's not fantastic.
Oh, I don't do it that way or, I don't see
how you could possibly do that ... but it's
great for "you" statements like why did you
make that decision, why did you chose this
thing, for giving constructive feedback it's
not. You picked the wrong plug‑in, you should
change it. Or you should chose the completely
wrong coding style, you need to go fix it.
That's not pushing people forward into improving.
And the mediums which we communicate are very
important to‑‑ and at work we have several
different platforms for communicating. In
general we have slack, and I feigned slack
to be one of the best tools out there, for
communicating just in general and keeping
in touch with people. Stand ups, either on
some kind of video chat or in person is very
nays for getting that face‑to‑face time,
quick interactions and finding out what's
going on with someone. Regarded discussions
that you can reference later, GitHub issues
or trouble card or issue tracker are great
and some kind of long tomorrow or acinous
communications that doesn't have to be triggers
right I way or answered right away (Asynchronous)
remembering these made yums helps us get the
right communication methods and helps us get
the right return of information that we're
expecting at the right time. We can create
communication too, one of the words that I
hear a lot from people that is another bummer
for me is "it sucks" I really don't like this
because it eliminates any hope of improving
upon anything. It's very negative. It doesn't
push people forward, and improving, and unless
you're talking about something like DJ Roomba,
I don't want to hear about something sucks,
it doesn't help me or others. And when we're
using these open channels when communicating
with a community, Slack is great, Gitter,
which is kind of a Slack alternative on top
of GitHub IRC has been around over and even
GitHub issues are very important. Slack I
really like because you can customize things
to encourage better feedback and communication
from your community. Recently we added a little
Slackbot that recognizes things like "sucks"
and encouraging more description and feedback
in relation to that. And anyone can do that.
It's very easy to do. You can add multiple
integration that fit with how you want the
community to act and communicate with you.
And taking the time to do that is all about
caring, taking the time to do any of this
is all about caring. And caring is providing
the needs of something, and generally showing
an interest in it. If we care about something,
we're interested in it, we want to do something
about it. And caring over all is sharing.
It's listening again, always listening and
understanding. Like I said before, empathy
is feeling and understanding with people,
not for people. And as such a minute detail
that one word, but a super important. And
showing how much you care. Do you care enough
to write a Blog post? To file an issue? How
much time do you have? Can you send an e‑mail.
Is there an e‑mail available? Can you record
screen cast, that's great. There's such great
tools out there to quickly record even a Gif
or full screen cast that you can post to an
issue or a pull request for what you're doing
or when submitting a pull request. If you
have time to fix 2 code if you know how to
do it. If you think their code is unstructured
or using the wrong module, to you care enough
to take the time, change that, submit a pull
request and communicate with them to make
sure that if you're using it then you want
it to be better and show it, show them how
you can make it better. And then very important
to remember also, don't give in to the hate.
It leads 20 Dark Side. Yoda, he knew what
he was talking about. It's such an important
thing to remember, stay positive, encourage
positivity in the community, and part of that,
and part of caring, putting time into something
comes into documentation. At least for me
at work, I find it so important to remember
this. Wikis, code comments, style guides,
pattern libraries, READMEs. Any of these things
can help either new developers or veteran
developers, reference old code, new code,
and go through code reviews and get context
from that right away and speed up the process
maybe. Any little thing that we can add to
our project will helm tremendously and then
remember to make issues for documentation
and keeping it up. And such a way of doing
this helps exsimplify caring. And another
way to do that even not just at work and but
in the community is mentoring. Mentoring is
really interesting, you can have a mentor
and men tee at the same time, we're all at
different stages in our skill set, and our
skills (Mentee) in general, but do we remember
starting out and how much we wanted a mentor
to learn from, we can be that for a junior
developer and a senior developer ahead of
us be our mentor D you have a mentor when
you started out? And how much did you want
one? And did you want to learn? You can learn
from having a mentor, you can learn from having
a Mentee. We saw earlier that teaching someone
helps improve our understanding of a concept.
It really helps push forward our understanding.
And in order to start contributing these ideas,
these tenants to our companies, we can start
just by listening for a difficult start small.
Start listening, maybe not always having to
voice an opinion, to voice a bias. And start
applying these small examples that I talked
about before. Code reviews. Using the right
channels, using the right statements. Starting
off small and then remaining open to sharing,
remaining open to listening and asking why.
And for some people, it sounds like too much
work, to keep remembering this, to keep remembering
that oh, I have to remember to think about
people, to care. Yes, that's Oooh, that's
so much work. And to them I say, well, deal
with it. Because by starting to apply empathy
to connect with others professionally at first,
it leads us down this path to connecting with
others personally. This is a small space and
a small area to start out with. We all have
something in common when we start out with
working on the web, working with products,
working with JavaScripts. That's that small
connection that can lead to bigger connections
and understanding others. And for following
up, and following a resources, one of my favorites
and probably the first place I go to is suggest
for others is a book called practical empathy.
This leads to more general examples and more
general like research around working with
others, and using empathy that way. While
my example is more specific to our industry
and development and design. And I also like
to collect resources as well and recently,
used to be on my own web site,now I've decided
to dedicate something else to that. So this
went live yesterday, it's called the other
side of empathy.com, just try to gather empathy
on the web and share it with others and give
people a place to find new resources, keep
up to date, with any medium, pod casts, Blog
posts, research papers, videos. But it's also
available while I was lacking up this domain
at more‑empathy.online. So I really like
that, and I think you can access it anywhere
and it describes what I'm trying to do, and
who I hope otherrings can try to do. I love
hearing more about it. It's open, it's on
my GitHub, you can also suggest resources
that way, improvements to make this more accessible
for others and more open. And that's about
it. So, thank you. (Applause).